サッバパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタングブッダナササナン
では よろしくお願いします
それとですね  この月例講演会始めたのは
このお釈迦様の教えをね
元の教え 日本の現代の方々にね
わかりやすく紹介しようという目的でしたからね
まあ悪い汚れた言葉で言えば
テーラワーダ仏教というか
初期仏教の宣伝講演ですね
これは宣伝になるどころか
ものすごく難しくなってしまっちゃって
逆効果になっちゃって
ブッダの教えからみんな逃げることになってしまったんですよ
難しすぎて まあそれほど仏教は難しいとは思わないんだけど
我々の気持ちがね いろんなもう歴史の中でね
混乱していてね だから生命っていうのはね
何千万年からもね どんどん進化してきたんだから
他の生き物とね 大した変わりがない生き方をしてますよ
ただ種は違いますからね
鳥たちは鳥たちの生き方ありましてね
獣には獣の生き方がありまして
人間には人間の生き方あるだけの違いなんですね
根本的にはそれほど変わってないんです
だからお釈迦様がまあそれで突然いきなりすべて乗り越えた真理の世界を語っているんだから
ちょっと理解どうかなということもあるかもしれません
ちょっと聞いてみると
まあそんなに難しい話ではないんです
ただ 我々の気持ち 感情が割り込んできてね
邪魔するだけなんですね
それから仏教って言ったら宗教だろという固定概念に入っちゃうんですね
日本人は宗教 一般的には宗教嫌いですよ
それは仕方がないんですね
まともな人はあんまり宗教の込みないんですね
ちょっと変な人々はなんか変な迷信的なね
カルト的な宗教を作りますけどね
既成的な宗教っていうのは
まあ微妙にカルトっぽいところはあるんだけど
そんなにカルトではないんですけどね
しかし この宗教組織が結構人類にはね
いろんな迷惑をかけてきましたし
それからかなり排他的であるしね
そういうことでちょっと違和感感じるということになるんですね
何か宗教を信仰する場合は
何かいろんなものから縁を切らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんだからね
それはあまり好きじゃないんです
だから現代宗教っていうのは文化であってね
カルチャーですよ だから西洋人は基本的にキリスト教で
中東の人々は基本的にイスラム教でというふうにね
カルチャーですよ あまりこの真剣に信仰する人っていうのはほとんどないと思いますけどね
それで仏教もなんかね
宗教だと思っちゃいますから
それは構いませんよ 宗教と思うんだって
仏教は 2500年以上古いんだから
カルチャーにはなってますよ
仏教文化っていうね カルチャーになってくると
宗教っぽいものっていうのはすごい大きくついてくるんですね
だからお経を開ければ
しきたり習慣があるわ
いろいろそういう でも本当は釈尊が全くそういうしきたり
習慣 いろんなものに断った
凝り固まった生き方を教えたわけじゃないんですね
純粋にもう科学者のように真理を語り続けただけなんです
だからかなり大胆なんですね
だから私が今頑張っているのは
その純粋なところ 信仰はひと欠けらもない
ただ客観的に物事を見たらどうなるかっていうと
こうところ説明をしているんですよ
それはなかなか世の中で
仏教の世界でもよくやらないんですね
仏教の世界もどちらかというと
文化に乗って乗され乗せられてしまうんですね
はい それはわけもわからない話で始めたんだけど
とにかく今日のテーマに行きましょうか
今日のテーマは あの ちょっと色合いはね
あまり良くないなってね
まあ面倒くさいんだから
あまり関係ない 気にしなかったんですけど
できるだけ見えるようにはしたんですけど
あのブッダの栄養学ですね
えっと 次の単語よくね
心の心の栄養を管理してみませんか？という副題で
それで私たちはこの出家しようと思って
ちっちゃい時ね お寺に入ったら
一番最初に暗記される本がありましてね
沙弥のテキストっていうね
昔からできたもので その中
もうあの本もほとんど暗記しなくちゃいけないんですよ
結構ありますよ 沙弥のテキストで言ったっても
で あれ暗記しちゃえば
それだけで比丘になれるぐらい能力はついてくるんですね
そちらにこの沙弥の 10種類の質問ということがあってね
で それは暗記してますよ
第1は一つは何？という質問なんですね
釈尊が 7歳の沙弥に聞いた質問だそうです
一つとは何と 答えられますかね
この沙弥は答えたんですよ
なぜ答えられたのかというと
このちっちゃい割に裸になっていたんです
だから我々俗世間が考える１ではなく
仏教は命 生きることの学問だから
生きることに対する科学です
学問じゃないんです 生きることの科学は世の中でないんです
命とは何ぞや？ライフとは何か What
is living?とかね
そういう科学はないんですね
物理学はいろんなものがありますけどね
医学もありますけどね
遺伝子を研究するマイクロバイオロジーもありますね
微生物の学問とかね 命ということは
科学の研究テーマになっていないんですね
仏教はそれを精密に完璧な科学的に見ているんですね
だからお釈迦様が１とは何と聞いたら
これはあの生命というところから答えなくちゃいけないんですね
数学で１って何と定義できるんでしょ
これパーリ語でエカナーマキン
答えはサッブディサッタアーラティティカ
意味は答え すべての生命は栄養に支えられている
これが生命に対して１なんです
生命であれば栄養にサポートしておかなくちゃいけない
これはどれぐらい このアーハラティティカっていう言葉は
ちょっと日本語の単語を思い出せなかったんだけど
我々はすべての人間と生き物が地球の上にいるんですね
だから地球に 支えられているんですね
空を飛ぶ鳥たちも 地球の引力によって空を飛んでいるんです
引力に逆らうわけじゃないんです
我々は決して無重力でいるわけじゃないんですね
そのように だから我々の血管やら心臓やら
すべての細胞の働きは
この地球の引力があった上で成り立っているんです
で そんなような感じで
まあ土台ですね 支えられている
栄養というのは 生命の
これでちょっと解説に行きます
サッビーサッタ アーハラッティティカ
ティティカっていうのは
栄養が支えられて成り立
栄養によって成り立っている
アーハラっていうのは
パーリ語で普通に食べ物って意味なんですね
これでアーハラっていうのは
言語学的に言えばこの外から取り入れる
アーハルティという動詞から作るんです
このパーリ語 サンスクリット語
これから私たちが使っている国の言葉とか
すべて動詞から作るんですね
名詞は すべて言語の元は動詞なんですね
だからアというのは外から自分の方を向かうプリフィックスで
接頭語なんとかというんですね
頭につけてハラっていうのは取る
テイキング アーハラというのはテイクインなんですね
インというのは自分の中に
それを名詞にしたら食べ物という風に使うんですね
いわゆる取り入れるもの
アーハラは取るという動詞からできた単語です
すべての生命は何かを取り入れなくては命は繋げません
説明しましたね 命っていうのは何か取り入れて
取り入れて取り入れて生きていかなくちゃいかんですよ
ちょっとくだらない例え話になります
照明 電球が光っている
何の変化もなく明るさがあると安心する
しかし 瞬間でも電気の流れが切られたら光も消える
私たちの命は電球ではなく
電球が放っている光のようなものです
命っていうのは光のようなものだと思って
これ例え話ですよ あまり神秘的に理解しないでください
ずっと光があると我々思っているんですね
でも光がずっと電力で支えなくちゃいけないんですね
ちょっとでも電気切れたら光がないんです
でも我々はそれを無視して
電気のことをすべて無視して
ああ 明るいんだとかね
と思っている 太陽の光の場合も
そうすると太陽が燃えて燃えてエネルギーを出さないと光にならない
命とは儚いもので 常に他のエネルギーで支えておかなくてはならないということですね
だからそれだけでも仏教は違うとご理解できると思いますよ
だから哲学者たちが 宗教家たちが
命はありがたい 命は永遠
命には何よりも価値がある
命こそ尊いものやとか
何かもののように取り扱っているんですね
ものの命取り扱っているならば
この遺伝子をガチャガチャ研究する方々は命を発見するはずなんです
例えば単細胞の命もありますね
これはもう精密に科学者は分析
分析して研究しているんですよ
知らないものは何もないです
しかし 生きているということはわからないんですね
生きていると推測するだけで
何か何か決まった働きをやっているって生きていると思っているんだけど
命っていうことがよくわからない
だから科学者がこの宇宙とか地球でどうやって現れたのかとかね
地球で最初の命はどのように誕生したのかとかね
まだまだわかってないんですね
それはわかるはずもない
だって命はこういうものは定義がないんだから
そこで仏教はもう最初から定義で始まるんですね
そこですよ みんな仏教を嫌いな理由は
本当のことを言うんだから
ものすごい嫌なんですね
だからわけもわからない状態でいるのが気持ちいいみたいんですね
どうかな？とかね うん
で 嫌味言うのをやめて
こういうふうに出ます
で そこでたとえ話で言うならば
命とは光であると思うならば
例えば太陽の光のようなものじゃなくて
小さな小さな電球で 蛍光灯で
LED で いろんなもので光を放っているでしょうに
そこで LED ではなく
LED が放している光が命だと思うと
思うと何がわかるんですかね
これすごい儚いもので
何か何かの原因で一時的に現れた現象なんです
LED に光がないんです
しかし  LED の中に微妙な電気が通ると
LED がちょっとおかしくなっちゃって
光のような波を出しちゃうんですね
だから光はある意味ではありますよ
だって見えるんだからね
でもなんか変じゃない？もともとあったわけじゃなくてね
原因によって現れたものなんですね
だから アミノの塩基ね
4種類のね これ入る適当に
だから 1つのアミノ酸では命じゃないんですね
アミノ酸が塩基ではないんですね
これが 4つありまして
組み立てて組み立てて
結構組み立てて長くないと
大体ウイルスの遺伝子がすごい短いんですね
我々と比較すると短いんだけど
相当長いんで それでも
それぐらいなければ ウイルスという不安定な命さえ成り立たないんですね
はい 今日のポイントはそれでもないんですね
LED が電球が光を放しているならば
そうっと電気が入ってもらわないと成り立たない
それで我々の命って まあもう肉体で生きているでしょ？ 40兆ぐらいの細胞の組織を作って
なんか生きている その細胞たちに
その遺伝子たちに すーっと何かエネルギーを与え続けなくちゃいかんです
それでこれ回転しているんです
だから遺伝子を回転させる
あのエネルギーにアーハラ栄養というんですね
そこで皆様方はね  1 日 3食食べてますよとかね
まあ 4回 5回ぐらいは液体も飲んでますよとかね
思ってはいるんだけど
実はそうじゃないんですね
体の細胞たちには 24時間絶えず栄養をあげなくちゃいけないんです
栄養なくなると壊れるんです
それで凶暴な細胞たちは
栄養が入らないと隣のものを奪っちゃうんです
だから我々は断食しちゃうと
体にあるいろんな細胞が壊れて
そこのエネルギーを奪ってったりするんです
だからどうしてもエネルギーはスーッと切断せず供給しなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば我々呼吸しているでしょう
それもエネルギーですけど
だからすーっと細胞たちに酸素が必要なんです
たまたま我々の息を止めることはできますよ
これは息を止める機械はほんのちょっと止めるだけで
細胞組織が呼吸酸素なく生きられるわけじゃないんです
だから命っていうのはそういうものなんです
尊いとか立派とか 永遠不滅である
こんなことは非科学的で
迷信で信仰のみ希望のみなんです
科学的事実ではありません
科学というのは 仏教を科学的に見ても事実ではありません
だから命っていうのはものすごい
一番儚いものは命なんです
世の中でいろんなものは無常で
すぐ消えるでしょう 私は最近使っている言葉っていうのは
シャボン玉よりも命が儚いものであると
ものすごい 例えば電気が切れたらどれぐらい光残る？瞬間も残りませんね
電気が消える同時に消えちゃうんです
蛍光灯はちょっと違いますけどもね
蛍光灯はもうちょっと光ってはいるんだけどね
電気消してっても普通の光はそうじゃないんです
でもシャボン玉はもっと持てますよ
例えば実験したらね 電気をスイッチ入れてシャボン玉を作って
電気を消してシャボン玉を見ると
またシャボン玉があるんですね
電気は光が消えちゃったんです
そういうわけで このその命っていうのはすごい儚いものである
いつでも支えてあげなくちゃいけない
これはもう終わりなく支えてあげなくちゃいけない
ホッとする瞬間はできないんです
そこは命の定義として理解してください
命を支え続けるエネルギーはアハラと言います
はい これからまあ経典に入ります
チャッターローメビッケベアーハラブータナンワサッタナンティティアサンバベシーナワアヌッガハヤ
比丘たちよ 生まれた生命を維持する
生まれようとしている生命のさすのじゃない
生命を支えるアーハラは栄養は 4つですと
4つのアーハラあるんです
だから 4つのエネルギーで命をサポートしている
4本の足みたいなもんですよ
テーブルは 4本の足があって
椅子は 4本の足があって
椅子になっているんですね
足がなくなったら椅子ではなくなっちゃうんです
4本の足がある椅子が 1本なくなっても相当やばいんですね
そこでお釈迦様はこの生命を 2つに分けてます
説明あるかどうかよくわかりませんんだけど
出来上がった生命だけではなく
今から生まれようとするものの命をサポートすることも栄養の仕事です
だから今 我々はブータというもう出来上がっているんです
まだ成虫というかね 成長していない生命
まだまだ工事中の生命はサンバベイシーというんですね
これあんまりどちらかというとよくわからない
なぜならば お釈迦様が生命と言ったら
地球上の生命だけじゃなくて
いろんなものを すべての宇宙のすべての生命のことを考えて語っているんだから
まあちょっと私達にとってはわかりませんだけど
我々が知っている世界で考えましょうか
例えば 女性が妊娠する
妊娠した瞬間から命が命ですよ
でも人間として扱うことはできない
大体 2週間ぐらい ただの細胞の塊で
で それでどんどんおなかの中で 10ヶ月間人間として育ててくるんですね
それで人間になったならば
おなかから今準備OK
出ていきますと出ていくんです
それから卵 卵から鳥が現れるんですね
でも卵は鳥じゃないんですね
まあ今調べて知ってるだけで
卵だけ見てどんな鳥かわからないでしょう
どんな卵を割ってみたっても
中にあるのは白身と黄身だけなんですね
ヘビの卵を割ってみたっても同じことなんです
卵が命ですが サンバベシーなんですね
工事中の命 だから工事完了した命と工事中の命
どちらでも命ですから
ずっと栄養がサポートしなくちゃいけないんですね
はい それからカメチャッタール
この 4つの栄養とは何ですかね
物質的な栄養 カバリカラーをアハローオーラーリコはスクモは
粗きものであろうと詳細なものであろうと
物質的食べ物 物質的な食べ物
このカバリカラーっていうのは
人間と動物のことを見て使っている
取って食べる おにぎりみたいにね
パンでもちぎって食べる場合は
それをカベリと言うんですね
それで私たちはそうやって具体的に塊として取って取って口に入れちゃいますけど
そうでなく 微妙に栄養を受け取る生命もいるんですね
口で食べることはしない生命もいる
それで生命の体っていうのは物質です
これで神々さえも体を持っているならば物質です
幽霊も餓鬼も全部体を持ってるならば
幽霊なんか人間に見えないんですね
だから人間に見える波長の物質を持ってないんですね
だからといって体を持ってるならば物質です
体を構成する物質の特色は簡単に壊れていくことです
って面白いんですよ この例えばこのパソコンやらテーブルの物質はそう簡単に壊れませんね
持ちます この体の物質は同じ世の中の物質ですよ
仏教的に言えば地水火風ですけど
あるいはもう酸素やら炭素やら水素やら
そういうものなんですよ
もう炭素 酸素 水素などなどは結構持ちますけど
体作っちゃうと壊れるは壊れるはなかなか
なんかあの玉ビー玉で何かすごい
何か子供が何か面白い家を作るような感じなんですね
なかなか大変でしょ ビー玉は一応
例えばピラミッド 二度型とかね
四角いのように組み立てられますけど
大変なんです 壊れてしまいます
だからビー玉でピラミッド作ってくださいと誰かに頼んだら
その人は一生苦労しなくちゃあかんのです
完了できないんです はい
完成でできないんです
ズルをやらないと 例えば糊で貼っちゃうとかね
糊は使ってはいけませんと言ったならば
どうしますか？これ不可能です
永遠に作って 作って 作って作っていなくちゃいけないんです
命はそういうものなんです
命といっても肉体が ビー玉でピラミッドを作ってみようかなと思う
ピラミッドというのは
なんか頭で考えれば作る作れそうでしょ
ビー玉で柱を作ろうと思ったら
それは不可能ですから
ピラミッドのようにものをしましょう
なんとなく考えればできそう
じゃあやってみてって
できない ずっともう 組み立てなくちゃいけないんです
止まることなく 体の物質は体から逃げているんです
欠けていく物質を えーと
何て言うか これは補わないと命も壊れてしまいます
ただ 私は水を飲んできたんだけど
飲んでる瞬間でも 飲んで終わった瞬間でも
体からすーっと水分が絶え続けていくんです
あまりもたくさん出て行っちゃったら
また補わなくちゃいけないんです
ストップはないんです
食べ物を通して生命は物質を
補給しているんですね
壊れるものを補給しているんですね
水が出ていったら水を入れる
エネルギーがなくなったらエネルギーを入れてあげる
鉄分がなくなったら鉄分を入れたり
鉄分そうではなくて 食べ物として入れてあげる
炭素が減っていったら
もう炭素は食べられませんだけど
ご飯とかなんとかで炭素を入れてあげる
そういう風に壊れているものはずっともう補修補ってあげなくちゃいけないんです
補給しなくちゃいけないんです
はい 次に行きましょうか
何を食べればという もし肉体がH2Oであるならば
壊れていくのもH2Oでしょ
だったらH2Oを入れればいいんです
簡単です 答えは でもそう簡単でもないんですね
肉体を構成する物質に合わせて決めなくちゃいけない
それで 私たちの肉体が構成している物質に適したもので補わなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば炭素がなくなったところで水素を入れていいわけじゃないんです
だから 犬の体にも炭素が必要だし
我々の体も炭素が必要ですけど
その形が合わないと まあ大体同じ遺伝子を持ってるんだから
ほぼ同じことで大丈夫ですけどね
考えなくても 研究しなくても
生命は何を食べれば良いのかとわかっているんです
これ 人間が頭おかしくて問題にしてるだけで
犬は何を食べればいいかってわかってますよ
犬は肉を食べる たまにパンとかも食べる場合もあるし
ご飯も食べる場合もあるし
育ち方によって しかし
いくらなんでも 例えばニンジンは食べない
食べて死ぬわけじゃない
食べないんですね キュウリも食べる犬は私は知っていた犬がいたんだけどね
人間食べるものは何でも食べちゃうというよね
だから私はあるこの人はね
お新香は食べないでしょと言ったら
飼い主がね 食べますよと
人間食べるものだったら何でもあげてみたら食べるんですね
で  それは特別なケースで死ぬわけじゃないんですね
でもカラスは知ってます
何食べればいいかと スズメは何食べればいいかとね
トンビは何食べればいいかと
それで昆虫だけ食べる生物いますね
昆虫しか食べない アフリカにいるでっかい動物
アリクイなんとかっていうね
アリクイ何でしたっけ？アンチウチョウと英語で言いますけどもね
で アリしか食べませんね
だから体大きいんだけど
すごい臆病でかわいそうなもの
もうあまり速く走らないし
捕まること取ることもできるだそうですけどね
で 攻撃できないんですね
口がアリを食べるためにできてる口だから
もう歯もないしね 人間に攻撃与えることもできないんです
だからアリクイ虫のお母さんがね
あんたはこれからアリを食べて生活しないと後ろはありませんね
そのその生物とは だから人間も何食べればいいかっていうことは知ってるはずなんです
それで我々は原始時代でも生きていたんだからね
学校も何もなく 動物の中でほとんど野生の動物と同じ状態で生きていたんですね
その時もこれを食べればいい
これを食べてはいけないと知っていたんです
だから何を食べればということはあまり問題ではありませんね
体に必要とする物質の形に合うものは自然に受け入れます
そこで自分の体の物質の形に合うものは
なんとなくはめていくんですね
形に合わないものを拒否します
だから形に合わないものが入っちゃうと
それは拒否します だから我々はいろんな葉っぱ食べてますけど
一部の葉っぱだけなんですね
どんな葉っぱでも このいろいろ生け垣とかありますから
そこら辺に葉っぱでも取って食べてはいけ食べませんね
食べて死ぬわけじゃないんだけど
なんかまあ嫌です そんなのは食べませんと
もうサラダ食べますと
レタス食べますということになっちゃうんですね
キャベツ食べますと ホウレンソウ食べますと
なぜかというと なんか微妙に型が合わないんですね
キャベツの場合は型が合うんですね
あるいは場合によって体が壊れて死ぬこともあります
葉っぱあります 食べたら死ぬ葉っぱも
で 結構あります みんな研究しないんだから食べてみてください
どんなどれくらい食べたら死ぬ葉っぱがあるのか
それは冗談ですけど 本当に食べたら死ぬ
葉っぱの種類もあります
ゆかりはコアラしか食べませんね
あれはどんな生物も食べませんね
形合わないんです ゆかりの油成分が入っていて
あれはゆかり 油が体に毒じゃない
面白いんですよ 筋肉痛とかで体に塗ったりすることはできますし
薬にも使っているしね
ユーカリプトゥスオイルというものは
しかし ユーカリプトゥス葉っぱは食べられないんです
食べちゃうと毒なんです
何を 食べれば良いのかと
存在欲 タンナー渇愛が決めるので
この点について誰も困らないんです
だから物質的な食べ物で何食べればいいか
困っちゃったなぁということはあり得ないんです
そう困っちゃったら生命が消えちゃうでしょうに
生命は消えませんね とにかく地球上の生命はとにかくあの
殲滅する生命もいるんだけど
やっぱり消えませんね
なんで生命は何を食べればいいかとわかるのかというと
これ 渇愛が存在欲が決めてくれるんです
存在欲があって この我々の場合は細胞ですから
遺伝子ですから この遺伝子に
まあこういう形のものを入れてくださいという風に存在欲が決めているんです
はい この渇愛が いわゆる存在欲が混乱するととても危険なんです
体に適した栄養は存在欲が決める
OK  OK  OK と これはダメ
これはダメ これは OK と選別するのは存在欲なんです
もし存在欲が酔っ払っちゃったらどうしますかね
それすごい危険なんです
選別できなくなるんです
存在欲とは 命が危うい状態にならない限り意識しない感情です
私たちはどれほど簡単に自然に生きられるかというと
大体人間は私に存在欲があるんだなと気づかないんです
気づく場合あるんですよ
この災害に遭遇したら
命が危うい状態になった瞬間で
事故を起こした瞬間で
さっと存在欲に気づくんです
あ 生きていなくちゃうと
あ やばいと そうでない限りは
何のことなく生きているんですね
存在欲がないような感じで
二次的に起こる欲 怒り
嫉妬 傲慢などの感情によって存在欲が暴れます
そこで存在欲から二次的に 1,500 の感情が生まれるんです
欲が生まれる 怒りが生まれる
落ち込みが生まれる 後悔が生まれる
傲慢が生まれる 嫉妬 憎しみが生まれる
物惜しみが生まれる いろんな感情が生まれるんです
大体その感情を知っています
ある程度でね 大体仏教を学ばなくたっても
人間はそういう欲 怒り
嫉妬などの感情は知っています
存在欲はあまり気づかないんですね
しかし この存在欲という水から
この波が荒波が生まれるんですね
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの それによって水が全体的に暴れちゃうんですね
それで存在欲が暴れるんです
その時選ぶ食べ物は 体には適しないで毒として働きます
怒りで食べ物を選んでみてください
それでも決定するのは存在欲だから
まあ食べ物は選ぶんですよ
でも選んだのは怒りですからね
怒りも張り込んだんだから
あの食べ物がちょっと体に良くない
今いろいろ看板を見たんだからね
歩いてくるとね うなぎ食べる時期になってきたんですね
うなぎの看板ね 予約してください
いろいろありましてね
そこであるうなぎはみんな日本人が大変大好きな食べ物で
ごちそうやと思っているしね
もうすごい栄養あると思ってるし
それはそちらの方でどうでもいいんだけど
私は脂ありすぎやと思いますけどね
それである人が 自然に穏やかな気持ちで
じゃあうなぎでも食べましょうかという
ある人が見栄で 欲で あるいは怒りで
競争心でもう誰ももう先に買う前にもう行って買ってやるな
ふざけないとかね 行ってすごい凶暴な気持ちでうなぎ買って食べると
同じ店で弁当 2つ買っても
一つの弁当は体に栄養のある一つの弁当には毒が入っているんです
あの感情によって だからうなぎそのものに毒があるわけじゃないんです
存在欲が決めるんだから
暴れた存在欲が決めたか
落ち着いた存在欲が決めたかなんです
それによって体に合うか合わないかと
だから怒りで 嫉妬で 落ち込みで
で またいろいろ精神的な状況が良くない状態で食べても体が壊れるんですよ
同じ家で一人が明るくて楽しく優しい気持ちでいる
一人がすごく引きこもりで
怒りで憎しみで生きている
どちらの体が不健康になる？お母さんが二人にも同じ食べ物をあげていますよ
だから心が汚れている人の存在欲も暴れている
存在欲には汚れっていうことはないんだから暴れるんです
暴れた存在欲で食べる食べ物にはは
食べ物は毒に回します
だから体が壊れていくんです
人は誰でも感情で食を選んだり食べたりするので
食べ物から起こる諸問題には限りがありません
この世の中で食べるもののせいでどれほどトラブルがあるのかというと
生活習慣病というもう大量の病気のリストがありますよ
食べるものから生まれるんです
風邪引いたりとかね 鳥インフルエンザにかかったり
デング熱にかかったりするのは
これはもうウイルスのせいだからね
そんなに大きな問題ではありません
解決できます しかし 普通に食べたから病気になったこと
高血圧 コレステロール
動脈硬化 糖尿病 そういうものはどうしますかね
だからそこはお医者さんがわかっているところで
誰だってあまり体調が良くないでしょうに
いつでも元気ピンピンで活発でいるわけじゃないんですね
なんか調子が悪い なんかだるいとかね
あるんですよ だからそれは食べるもののせいなんです
食べるもののせいではなく
選んだ心のせいなんです
選んだ時と食べる時の気持ちで
こう簡単に俗っぽく 子供っぽく理解しましょう
コンビニでおにぎり 2つ買ってきて
二人で食べる 一人がものすごく怒って
もう精神的に不安定な状態でいる
一人がニコニコ穏やかでいる
そうすると 同じ会社で同じ機械で作ったおにぎりだから
全然問題ありません しかし
穏やかで明るくいる人の場合には
毒性が極めて少ない 気にする程度ではありません
そこで精神的に 混乱している人にとっては
あれが体に悪影響を与える
私は毒になるということは
あえて使う単語なんです
その方がインパクト強くて理解しやすいんです
怒ってご飯食べると ご飯が毒になりますよと思った方が戒めできるでしょ？だから私はネットで悪口を言うんじゃなくて
私は精密に物事を考えて言葉を使っているんです
皆様のことを心配して
だからちょっと極端的な大胆的な単語を使います
暴れた心でおにぎりを食べると毒になると
落ち着いた心でおにぎり食べると体の栄養になると
これであの聞いた話ですけど
アメリカでも 例えば前の大統領
誰でしたっけ？クリントンさんとかはね
結構ハンバーガー食っちゃいますね
ハンバーガーとクリントンみたいなでっかい金持ちが食べるもんじゃないんですよ
このファーストフードのね
って喜んで食べてるんですね
ビル・ゲイツは昔は好きでしたそうですね
大金持ちになる前には
で それでこのホームレスとか
いろんな人々は そういうファーストフードだけ食べてる人々いるんで
あれは本当に油ばっかしで
グリースと英語で言いますけどね
グリースばっかしで もうもう直ちに心臓が壊れるぐらい危険なんですけど
やっぱり元気なんです
理由は その人々はすごく喜んで落ち着いているんですよ
気持ちが明るいんですね
すごい明るい気持ちで
汚れてない心で いつでも明るくできるならば
毎日マクドナルドを食べたっても大丈夫なんです
それはもう言い過ぎなんですけど
一応論理的なところを理解してください
存在欲が暴れると 食べ物は毒に回すと
はい ではブッダのアドバイス
肉体を維持することを考えて食べる
だから食べる前の科学者になってほしい
この感情の塊になってはいけません
科学者になって体が壊れている
常に壊れている 壊れる
壊れる 壊れる 壊れる 停止なすなく壊れる
じゃ ものをものを入れなくちゃいけない
形の合うものを入れなくちゃいけないと
そこを観察って これちょっと理解するの
その瞬間で 食べるものを見た瞬間で
あ 部品交換やと理解してください
体に壊れた部品を取り入れる
それだけ簡単でしょ？あ
これは美味しいぞとかね
このお店の何でしたっけ？寿司はアメリカの大統領も食べましたよとかね
そんなことで食っちゃったら毒なんです
日本の総理大臣がアメリカ代表すると言った寿司屋さんに行って寿司食べましょうとかね
食べないでください 毒になります
まあ金があれば まあもう面白いんだから試そうかなというのは構いませんよ
しかし 明瞭って言っちゃうと
これ良くないんですね
だからそれも良くない
科学者になる これは部品交換だけです
部品交換しますと感じる
感情を重視するのではなく
理性に基づいて食べる
感情を重視するっていうことは
有名な食べ物から珍しい食べ物だから
今は時期だから 今は旬だからとかね
そういうどうでもいい非科学的な気持ちを抑えてください
理性に基づいて食べてください
何て言いますか 炭水化物はこれぐらいで
じゃあ何でしたっけ？植物繊維も必要ですから
まあこれと入れて またまあこれこれタンパク質も必要ですから
じゃあこれで入れてとかね
そんな程度で食べ物を合わせてみてください
そうすると理性なんですね 1
日に必要な量を理解しておく
これがこの数字では言えませんよ
数字では1日1500キロカロリーとか言ってますけど
あの それじゃないと思いますね
で 私は体重計で測ってみたら
いつでも代謝はすごい多いと
値がすごく多いと出てくるんだけど
大将がすごい値といったらたくさん食べなくちゃいけないということになりますね
だから私の体には 1500 カロリーはものすごく多すぎなんです
ものすごく多いんです
少ないカロリーで生きていられます
ですから それぞれの人にとって普通の人間より2倍食べる人もいる 2
倍食べなかったら その体は維持できない
普通の人の食べ物の半分しか食べない人もいる
だから 自分の肉体が一日どれぐらいのもの必要だという必要かということは
各自で発見してみてください
この頭でっかちで考えてはいけません
自分で感じてみてください
あの物質足らなかったら
体がもっと出せと言うんです
もうちょっと食べなさいと
それ発見する方法っていうのは
私は瞑想で教えていますよ
食べる瞑想というもの
スローモーションで実況中継して
すべて噛み切って食べてみる
実況しながらそうすると脳がもう完璧
もうこれ以上食べるなよという信号を出してくれるんです
それがその肉体に必要な量なんです
瞑想しない場合は 煩悩が絡んでいるんだから
もうちょっと余分に必要になるかも
だから瞑想して量がわかったら
日常はそれよりほんのちょっと 10%から 15%ぐらい増やして食べれば十分だと思います
だからずっと瞑想中でご飯食べることもね
現実的にできない場合もありますからね
決して満腹にはならない程度で食べる
この満腹感が良くないんです
あれがあの存在欲が暴れているんです
暴れて不満とかね 自我とか出てきて食ってやると
時々日本でよくありますね
もったいない 言って食べちゃうでしょ
やめた方がいいと思います
もったいないと言って食べちゃうと
あなたの体に入るんだから
だから体に必要な量取ったら
残りはもったいないではなく捨ててください
とにかく満腹は良くないんです
食べ物は他の命なので
必ず慈しみの気持ちで食べてください
食べ物っていうのはどうも残酷ですよ
何かしらの命です キャベツであっても
ジャガイモであっても
サツマイモであってもね
何かしらの命なんですよ
だから食ってやるぞっていうことはすごい良くないんです
慈しみで生命が幸福になりますようにという気持ちがあって食べてほしい
その場合はブッダ お釈迦様は大胆に言うんですよ
慈しみの気持ちで食べると
食べたものは本当に毒であったとしたっても
毒は当たりません 体から逃げるんです
例えばもううなぎ弁当出ましたから
うなぎ弁当を食べているんだけど
誰か私を殺そうと思って
青酸カリをご飯の中にわからないように混ぜてあったとする
それ入ったらもうあまり味もないものでしょうに
死んじゃうでしょうに
しかし 私はずっと一口一口生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
食べるとあの成分が出ていくんです
細胞の中に入らないんです
それぐらい毒消し機能が慈しみの慈悲の瞑想にあります
体が常に壊れていくこと
維持管理することは大変であることなどに気づく
気づきながら食べる これは我々出家には指令なんですね
生きる苦しみは何者と毎日念じなくちゃいけない文章がある
ので私は毎日ダラダラッと念じますけど
真面目ではないんだけど
一応言ってるんだからやってます
で 苦しみって何ですか？と
ジャーティ ジャラー ビャーディ キューティー アパーヤ アティー タッパッタ グワッッタ ドゥッカ イダーニ
アハラ ガヴェッティ ドゥッカ サン メーガ ワット ニ マニアッタという経を毎日唱えています
ジャーティ ジャラー ビャーディ
生まれること 老いること
病気になること チュティ
死ぬこと 地獄 イダーニ アハラ ガヴェッティ ドゥッカ
今ここで食べ物を探さなくちゃいけない
必死で それは 4つ  8つの苦しみであると
輪廻転生する者にはと
だからその一行を取ったんですけど
あの 食べるものは毎日探さなくちゃいけないんです
鳥たち見てください 野生の動物たちを観察してください
野生はいないんだけど
皆様にはね いろいろ鳥たちとか見ると
いつでも食べ物を探していますね
昨日は鳩たちも見ましたけど
もう暑くて夏バテでドカンと倒れて
みんなドカンと倒れてるわ
餌を探していなかったんです
はい このアドバイスで食べるものを持っている毒が消えます
それから罪を犯してまで食べない
肉体は壊れて必ず死ぬので
罪を犯してまで食べる必要はありません
我々は食べる時 結構悪行為もしますよ
これやめてちょうだいと
なぜならどうしても死にますから
悪行為までして生きていたってもね
意味がないでしょうと
仏教は違法的に手に入る食べ物は汚染されているという意味で批判しています
これは出家の戒めでわかりやすい
在家の方々にそれほど教えてないんだからね
精密に仏教を教えられるというのは
お釈迦様が出家なんですね
なぜならば お釈迦様に命をかけている弟子たちだから
お釈迦様もすごい心配するんですね
例えば私が 焼き魚が食べたくなっちゃってね
誰かさんに言う これ間接的に焼き魚をくれと言っちゃうと
これハッキリ戒律違反だから
どうで元気ですかね あなたの
あんた料理上手で 特にあなたの焼き魚はね
あれものすごい微妙にすごい上手ですねと褒めてあげる
皆様 女性の方々はどうする？答えわかってるでしょ
あなたの魚の焼き方はプロにもかなわないよと言ってあげたら
必ずその女性が次の日私に焼き魚を持ってくるんです
それが汚染された食べ物です
それは出家者としては違法的に貰ったものなんです
時々私の体に合わない食べ物をたまたま女性の方々からもらったりもしますよ
そんなの本当は食べませんだけどと言ったら
相手が狂暴でね だから文句言わないで食べなさい
持ってきたんだからと怒られるんですね
そうすると私は何の文句も言わないで食べるんです
体には何のこともないね
その場合は なぜかというと
そちらであの人に対しても慈しみが自動的に生まれているんです
一生懸命食べてもらいたいという気持ちで作ったものだから
だから私は個人好みはどうであろうとも
そこまで頑張ってくれたから
やっぱりという気持ちで食べるんです
その場合は 体に自分の肉体に合わないものであっても
別に全然大丈夫なんです
だから出家にはこの違法的に食事を取るということが結構リストがあるんです
俗世間ではどういう風に？まあ例えばね
もう仕事を誤ったり 詐欺をやったり
インチキなことをやったりして
金儲けて それでどんなご馳走を食べても
その人は病気になります
体が壊れる それから残酷に生命を殺したり
野生の動物たちも生命を殺して食べているでしょう
でも お腹が空いたら1匹取って食べて終わる
人間そうじゃないんですね
殺して殺して殺しまくって冷凍保存しちゃうんですね
現代時代 そうなってますけど
その日の食べ物だけ入れれば本当は一番正しいんですよ
だから私たちにとってはそれでも軽らかに生活できますよ
だから その日のその日の食べ物を買って食べれば
商売商売をやっている人々のことはあまり気にしないで
かわいそうだと思っても構いませんし
それでも幸せになってほしいとね
みんな商売ですからね
仕事だからね かわいそうだな
大変だな 輪廻っていうのはね
恐ろしいものだなという優しい気持ちあってもいいんだけど
自分が食べる その日で食べるものは買って終わるとすればいいんです
存在欲と自分の命を守ることに限ります
存在欲とは この存在欲って誰にでもあるでしょ？気づかないんだけどね
たまに危険になったら気づきますね
この存在欲の力が この命を維持するだけで終わっているんです
周りの命を守ってあげることはできないんです
私の存在欲でこの命が維持する
皆様の存在欲で皆様の命が維持するだけです
例えばお母さんの存在欲でお母さんが生きている
お母さんの存在欲で子供まで生きていることはあり得ないんです
子供は子供の存在欲で生きていなくちゃいけないんです
たとえお母さんがおっぱいあげても
赤ちゃんが赤ちゃん持っている存在欲で生きているんです
他の命を守ることは管轄外です
できないんです だから生きとし生けるものは幸せでありますようにと思うことが
ものすごい高尚な道 男になるんです
存在欲に不可能なことをやっているんです
食べることについて 生命は残酷な態度を取るんです
ですから 食べることになると
相手の命は全く気にもしない
魚釣る人々は あ 取れた取れた
でっかいやつを取られた
取れたことを喜んでいるんだけど
取られた魚の命は全く無関心なんです
もし魚が暴れて逃げていったら怒るんです
この野郎 逃げられたに逃げられたと
魚に怒鳴るんです なんで餌食わないのかと
命でしょうに そこで魚釣りやってる人は自分の存在欲しか理解できないんですね
釣り餌食っちゃってぶら下がってるあの魚がの
あの痛み 悲しみ 恐怖感は感じないんです
だから食べるものになってくると
生命は残酷になるんです
それは存在欲のせいなんです
存在欲にはそれほど力がない
1個の命を支える力以外ありません
存在欲を他の命を守るという慈しみに入れ替えるべきです
ですから 罪を犯さないで食べるためには
たった一つしか方法がないんです
慈しみで食べるんです
はい 栄養に入りましょうか
栄養 1 終わりました 食べるものについて
パッソドゥディオ そこは第2の栄養です
眼耳鼻舌身意 色声香味触法が振られることが即です
あの六感にデータが振られる
触れることと即というんです
生きているとは認識機能が働いていることです
だって何も感じなかったらもう死んでるでしょうに
例えばマイクロフォンが生きていません
見られませんし 聞こえませんし
匂いは嗅げないし 音は聞こえません
何もできない だから感覚器官ないんです
この物体には 6つの感覚器官器官があるんです
それにデータが触れるんです
触れたデータを受け取ることとは
生きているということなんです
だから 生きているために
六感で常にデータを受け取り
受け取り続けなくてはいけないんです
触れて感じる機能を失ったら
直ちに生命は死にます
だから この手術をする時は麻酔をかける
麻酔をかけることが手術よりも危険なんです
体には 手術は体を開けることですけど
これは開けて閉めれば大丈夫ですけど
一番危険なのは手術中は麻酔なんです
麻酔で何するのかというと
この感覚器官が働かないようにする
だからまた復活させなくちゃいけないんだから
どこまで鈍くすればいいかと
いわゆる死んでないんだけど
殺した殺された状態にしているんです
あれ物質でやってるんだから
物質は常に与え続けなくちゃいけないし
物質をやめたら存在欲が喫緊して入り割り込んでまた意識が戻ります
だからこのものを感じるということ
生きることなんです 感じるためには触れなきゃ感じないんです
だから触れることがものすごい栄養なんです
触れることで生きているんです
食べ物とはもう違う世界なんです
食べ物は肉体という物体の時間で
物体だけ命じゃないんです
心も命なんです それには触れるということ
ずっとあの電球に電気がずっと流れていなきゃダメみたいな感じで
眼耳鼻舌身意にずっとデータが触れなくちゃいけないんです
そこで寝たら見えないでしょ
それで大丈夫です 意識が働いています
だから 6つも同時に働かなくてもいいんです
感覚が鈍くなることでも
生命は危機を感じます
味が分からなくなると
すごい危機を感じる 目が見えなくなると危機を感じる
耳が音が感じられなくなると
ものすごい危機を感じる
一番危機を感じるのは
体の観測が消えていくときなんですよ
もう怖くてたまらなくなるんです
足の感覚が消えたと 怖くなるんです
そこで存在欲が割り込んでくるんです
ということは 感覚がなくなったということは
触が機能しない 触れても受け取らない
例えば手の感覚が消えた
麻痺しました そうすると手を触っても私はわかりません
触っているんだけど そこがあるんだけど
受け取れないんです 栄養は取れないんです
それで手が死にます 目覚めるうちに感覚がなくなったら死んでいくんです
時々ありますね 生きているんだけど
体の一部は壊死するというね
認識することで貪瞋痴の感情が起きて存在欲を支えます
それで我々は見て聞いて味わって
嗅いで考えて貪瞋痴を作るんです
貪瞋痴を作って存在欲をね
存在欲をサポートするんです
それまた存在欲が暴れるんです
そちらでも 認識機能によって存在欲に感情をフィードバックするので
存在欲が暴れることは危険です
そこで目で物事を見る
見て なんて楽しいことか
なんて可愛いことですかとかね
なんて美しいことですかとか
なんて醜いですかとかね
なんて気持ち悪いですかとか
感情を作っちゃうでしょ
それは存在欲に入るんです
かえって存在欲が暴れるんです
それから生き方がどうなるかわからないんです
危険です 悪を犯して苦しみを増やして幸福を壊します
だから人間が眼耳鼻舌身があるから
悪を犯して不幸になるんです
輪廻転生から脱出できなくなります
触によって感覚が生じると
触も感覚も無常で流れるものだ
実体のない実体はないのだ
私でも私のものでもないのだという観察を大事にしなくてはならない
これを俗世間では期待できないんだけど
覚えておきましょう 触れること
眼耳鼻舌身意に これが栄養です
それで欲が生まれて 存在欲が暴れて
我々は苦しみの道を歩んでいるんです
そこで科学者になる 触れることは無常です
例えば触ったら 感じるね
どんな指で触るかとわかる
体に触れるものによって感触が変わります
だから無常でしょ だからそこが私ではない
私のものでもないと 無常だよと
流れるんだよと 何か見たっても
瞬間流れることやと なんて可愛いですかと
そこでしがみつく必要はないんだと
無常で消える 無常で消えるという観察すると
存在欲が暴れないんです
罪を犯せなくなります
栄養３に行きます これマノーサンチェータナタティヤ
心にある意志は第３の栄養です
意志 何かをしないと というふうに心に起こる衝動のことです
心の中でいつでも絶えず何かしなきゃ
何かしなきゃ 何かしなきゃと何かしているんです
常に行為をしているので
生き物は 常に行為させるエネルギーは意志というんですね
思考意で行為をしたいと思う衝動のことです
何かしなきゃ死にます
何かをすることが命を支えることです
見たい 聞きたい 歩きたい
座りたいとあるでしょ
それから何もない場合は妄想するでしょ
それで生き続けているんです
だから常に絶えず何かをする
何かをさせる その衝動エネルギーに第3番目の栄養というんです
これは心に常にあります
ない瞬間はありません
何もしたくないという瞬間はないんです
何もしたくないという人は何もしないという行為をやっているんです
この衝動があるからこそ
生命は生きているんです
そこでお釈迦様がおっしゃっているどんな栄養でも切られた瞬間で死にます
物質の栄養も切られた瞬間で死にます
電気と同じです 第２の栄養
触れること なくなった瞬間で死にます
第３番目の栄養 何かしたいと意志が消えた瞬間で死にます
この衝動に気づかないことは大問題になります
私たちの場合は この栄養はわからないんです
意志という栄養 欲という栄養
これを石たりしてはっきりしなきゃ
それによっても存在欲が暴れます
生命は常に何とかをやる
やる気がないことで不安を感じる
知ってますね やる気がなくなるとすごい不安を感じて
すごい苦しみになっちゃうんです
結果を気にせず なぜやるのかもわからず
止めることも制御することもできず
何かをやって感情を存在欲にフィードバックします
それを毎日でしょ？なんでやるのかわからない
何をやっているのかわからない
結果はどうなる？そんなことはどうでもいい
何かやりたいだけです
やってやって感情をフィードバックするんです
それで存在欲は暴れます
存在欲が暴れて悪に染まった生き方をする
だから普通の生命は悪に染まった生き方をしているんです
お釈迦様がおっしゃった生命科学を知っている人には
なんとか身を守ることができます
意志に気づかないと何かしたがる気持ち
命は苦しみから苦しみへと進む羽目になります
自動的に起こるこの悪感情
環境に気づかなくてはいけないんです
だから皆様はもう知っています
この意志に気づいてください
いつでも意志があるんだと
それで何かやって生きているんだと
だから意志は悪感情になるんだ
悪感 ったっけ？環境ヴィシャスサイクル
なんて言ったっけ？悪循環
悪循環になってますけど
この悪循環は我々ブッダの教えを聞いたんだから
これ破った方がいいんです
だから意志も制御します
貪瞋痴に気づく まず何かやりたいのはいいんだけど
やってください しかし
貪瞋痴はちょっと気をつけてください
意志は清らかか汚れているかを区別する
ご飯食べるのはいいんだ
食べたいという気持ちあるんだから
清らかな気持ちで食べている
汚れた気持ちで食べている
この衝動に気づくんです
例えばね 今夏だからアイスクリーム見たら
あ 食べたいなとかね それで
あの食べたいという気持ちは何でしょうかね
という風に その気持ちに気づいてください
意志っていうのは 2種類です
呼吸する 食べるなどの自然に起こる意志
これはもう悪か善か考える余裕がないんで
呼吸しています で 食べると言ったっても
この栄養が交換することが食べることなんです
口で食べることも一つですけど
体の中で栄養を交換していますね
それが本当の食べるものなことなんです
それはもう起こるんですね
仕事をする 話す 遊ぶなどの意図的に行為をすることも意志です
遊ぶ場合は自分で決めて遊んでいるんですね
その意志には気づきます
仕事をする場合は 自分の意志で仕事をしているんです
まず気づき 命に意志に貪瞋痴が入らないように気をつけた方がいいんですね
落ち着いている 遊んでもできるだけ落ち着いて
遊びから得るものだけ得て
落ち着いているという感じでいいんです
呼吸するなどはこの存在欲がやらせているんですね
その意志はあんまり気づかないんですね
両方に気づかなくてはいけないが
意図的に起こる行為の意志には必ず気づかなくてはいけません
本当は両方にも気づいた方がいいんですけど
瞑想をやっている人々は両方に気づくように成長しますよ
で 一般的にはこの 2番目の意志に気づいてほしい
気づいて汚れない 除けない
汚せ 汚さないようにした方が良いと思います
はい 最後に行きます 意志まだあります
意志の続きあります チェータナ
チェータナハン ビッカウェ カンマンワダミという言葉があります
業とは意志のことであり
と私は狙いですね は告げます
すごい大胆な言葉なんです
これ ブッダの意見なんです
業っていうのは意志のことですと
普通 皆様も知っている
業っていうのは何か神秘的で宗教っぽいでしょ？業が悪いとかいろいろ言ってる場合はね
これは過去の業じゃないかなとか言ってる場合は
なんか宗教っぽくて神秘的なんですね
でお釈迦様が大胆で 意志であると
業とは明言します 業を命を作って維持管理するエネルギーです
意志が貪瞋痴で染まったら悪です
意志が不貪不瞋不痴であるならば善です
意志という栄養素を汚染しないように気づきましょう
だからこれ業なんですよ
業も栄養になるんです
意志 何かする 何かをする
何もしないでいられることは不可能です
だから業が働かない 働かない瞬間がないんです
だったら意志を汚れないようにしましょう
善行為をして生きることに励みましょう
いい方 簡単な方法というのは善行為するんです
わざわざ わざわざ良いことを選んで選んでやっちゃいます
完全に善行為はできないかもしれませんだけど
仕事中でも悪いことするかもしれませんし
もう子育ての悪いことしちゃうし
いろんな時は我々の手で悪行為は起こしますけど
そこは置いといて わざわざと何かいいことでもしようかなとか
日本語であるでしょ  1日1善というね
これは最低限で  1日 1個
1個でも善行をやってくださいなんですね
1日1善では足りませんよ 1
日3善ぐらいやらないと
はい 最後の栄養に入ります
ヴィンヤーナンチャトゥッタン
識は 4番目の栄養です
認識しない瞬間はないが
認識する以前の心は識といいます
これ 識って認識ではないんです
認識したら識が変わっているんですね
だから認識する前の心が識というんですね
体が物体が命になるのは識が働いているからです
これは専門的な言葉で
私は瞑想する人々には言うのは感覚があるから生きているでしょうと
その方が瞑想する人にとっては経験できます
識はちょっと経験できないんです
ですから 瞑想ではこの専門の言葉はあまり使わないんです
はぁ それで これは物体ですよ
死んだ死体があるとしましょう
何がないかというと 識がないんです
瞑想する人から見ると感じないんです
触っても感覚がないんです
感覚が識じゃないんです
識があるから感覚が生まれるんです
識はちょっとわかりにくいんだから
瞑想対象にはしないんです
存在欲は識の中に起こるんです
私はずっと存在欲のこと言ったでしょ
存在欲が識の中に住んでいるんです
識によって存在欲が暴れることはない
と思った方がいいんです
今まで食べるものによって存在欲が暴れる
触れることによって存在欲が暴れる
意志によって存在欲が暴れると 3つも言ってきたでしょ
治る方法も教えたでしょ
識の場合は 識のせいで存在欲が暴れたということはないことにしましょう
したがって 管理する必要もありません
だから識の管理はないんです
楽ですね 一個だけ はい
それではあります 識の管理とは
色は純粋の水のようです
蒸留水みたいに 悪さはしません
色そのものが純粋 蒸留水みたいにただ H2O だけなんです
しかし 水に溶けるものによって
水は栄養になったり 毒になったりします
それで世の中で自然界で蒸留水は存在しない
雨も雨の一滴になった時点で蒸留水じゃないんです
何か塵と合わせて水に変わるんです
だから意図的に蒸留水を作ることはできますけど
作った瞬間からその水が変わっていくんです
例えば蒸留水はガラス瓶に入れてもガラスを溶けるんです
溶かすんです 時間経つと蒸留水じゃないんです H2O
ではなくなっちゃうんです
色相こう見つ法が触れて認識が起こると
貪瞋痴で汚染しないようにします
だから色は蒸留水みたいなことで
この水に何が溶けるのかと気をつけてください
だから皆様も水を飲んでいますけど
どんな水も飲まないでしょ
溶けることについて気にしますね
例えば 田んぼで水が流れていますよ
取って飲む 飲まない 川に水が流れる
取って飲む 飲まない しかし
湧き水がぶくぶくと出てくると取って飲む
なぜかというと 我々は何が溶けているかということをチェックしているんです
湧き水の場合は その水がフィルタリングしてから出ているんです
大地で それで大地のミネラルは入っているかも
それは体に大丈夫です
川はちょっとごめんと
そこで我々が飲んでいるのは全部この陸上にある水でしょ
陸上にある水はそんなに綺麗じゃないんです
地下の水は綺麗ですけど
飲まないんですね 大量に入れませんだからね
川の水とかダムを作ったりして
生活水として流れて そこで綺麗にして汚染物質を外して殺菌
殺菌して水道に入れちゃうんですね
だから水道の水は蒸留水ではありませんね
いろんなもの溶けてます
だからそれは大丈夫です
味噌汁は飲みますね いろんなものを溶けています
スープは食べます いろんなものが溶けています
紅茶も飲みます コーヒーも飲みます
お茶も飲みますね ジュースも飲みます
みんな水を飲んでいますけど
水に気をつ ないんですね
気づくのは オレンジジュースの場合は水ですよと思わないんで
オレンジ成分を気にするんです
ですから この溶ける成分に気づきましょう
色に溶ける成分 色に貪瞋痴は溶けないように気をつけましょう
意識が汚れないようにします
それから意識は汚れないようにする
そうすると色が大丈夫です
無執着は解脱ですが 執着も色の中に起こるんです
そこで仏教でいう解脱っていうのは
この無執着っていうことなんです
この無執着っていう状況が
どういうことかというと
執着が色にあるんです
色にはアクセスできないんです
我々は水にアクセスできない
溶けているもので水を理解する
お茶 コーヒーとかね 水とは言わないんです
お茶の成分入っている水と言わないでしょ
コーヒー成分入っている水とは言わない
食べるものの成分が入っている水とスープに言わないんです
だから水はあまり気にしないんです
この執着という状況も水に色にあるんです
あまりわからない そこで修行して執着捨てると色が純粋になっちゃうんです
完全無欠の心になります
はい これで講演は終わりましたが
4つの栄養の原因は何ですか？と
イメービッカレチャッターローアーハラキンサムデアキンジャーティカキンパバワ
比丘たちよ この 4つの栄養素の原因は何ですか？何によって生まれるのですか？どこから発生するのでしょうか？栄養素は
食べるものは外なんですけど
外にあるものは食べるものじゃないんです
本当は 私が取って口に入れると場合
食べ物なんです だから小麦粉は食べるものにするのは我々人間なんです
イメーチャッターローアーハラタンハーニダーナタンハサムデアタンハージャティカタンハーパバワ
渇愛がこの 4つの栄養素の原因です
渇愛によって生まれるのです
渇愛から発生します だから私は最初から渇愛の存在欲のことを説明してきたんです
お釈迦様はそれを最後のフレーズとして入れてあるんです
例えばある穀物がある
その穀物が私の渇愛によってご飯になるんです
ある植物が植物の実がある
私の渇愛によって その植物はかぼちゃスープになる
そういうことで 渇愛ですよ
全部決定するのは  4種類の栄養素は存在欲ですね
次にもう一つ勉強しなくちゃいけない色栄養素の特色
特権 キッセムコーバンテーヴィンヤーナーハーロー
尊師 色は何の栄養になるのでしょうか
ヴィンヤーナーローヤンアイティンプナッバハービーニバッティアパッキャヨ
色栄養素は再び生を作ることの原因になります
これは皆様にちょっとわかりにくいかも
この生を作る場合は色が働くんです
わかりやすく言います
お母さんのお腹に精子卵子が結合する
そちらに色が入るんです
色が入ったら命です だから命を作るのから再び生まれを作るのは色なんです
今 私に色がありますよ
色が瞬間瞬間無常ですよ
色も瞬間瞬間変化しても消滅しますが
死ぬ瞬間で私の今の色が次の色を作っちゃうんです
その次の色が新たな命になるんです
だから色が輪廻転生の栄養になります
輪廻転生する時の栄養資源になるのは色です
はい 栄養の管理 四つの栄養を汚染しないようにしましょう
幸福になります 節度を知って慈しみで食べる
善行為をする これまとめです
全部説明しました 食べるものの場合は
節度を知って慈しみで食べれば OK です
で 他は善行為すれば OK です
瞑想実践などで心を清らかにする
執着を断つことで 存在欲の問題を完全に解決する
一番怪しいものは存在欲ですよ
執着を断つ それで存在欲の問題は消える
で終わりです はい ありがとうございます
今日先生いろいろお話される栄養のお話をされまして
ちょっとそちらから若干飛躍した質問をさせていただきたいと思いますが
まあ先生 今日お話しされた栄養というのは
言葉を変えれば感覚の話をされたというふうに解釈しているんですが
こういった感覚というのは
まあ無常なものですので
こういう感覚にとらわれないようにしよう
こういう栄養とかにとらわれないようにしようとするというのが
仏教の目的だというふうに考えておりますが
それは目的というのは悟りということになると思いますが
ちょっとこの悟りについては段階あるというふうに思っておりまして
預流果 一来果 不還果 阿羅漢果
この段階のことにについてちょっとお伺いいたしたいんですが
この預流果というのに達して
預流果からこの最後のア羅漢果というものに達するまでの
大体どのぐらいの時間が平均的にかかるのかなというふうなことをちょっとお伺いさせていただきたいと思います
何か古代のインドの話を見ますと
そのバーフラさんという方とか
アーナンダさんという方とか
こういった方々の瞬間的に何か悟られたというふうなお話を聞いたことがあるんですが
平均的には平均的な人としては
大体この預流果から阿羅漢果というのは
どのぐらいの時間がかかるもので
ものなのでしょうか  うん
あの預流果になるまでは結構時間かかります
で この経典のエピソードをね
最後のエピソードだけ取っちゃうと誤解するかもしれませんね
生命は輪廻転生するんだから
このバーヒ バーヒエ尊者ももうものすごい長い時間
各世で修行しまった人なんですよ
で なんとかブッダの時代で友達が五
六人ね ブッダのお釈迦様の教えみたいに帰る説
なかったんですよ 当時のお習いは
みんな悟るんですね だんだんだらだらと
だから戒律を入れなくなっちゃったんですね
それで悟る人々が少なくなってくると
戒律もないんだから仏教が消えちゃうんですね
それで仏教がすごく消え始めたら 4
人5人かな 友達が比丘たちがね
これは大変なことで 我々は必ず悟らなくちゃいけないと思って崖に登ったそうです
崖にすごい険しい登りにくい崖に
はしごを持って登ったんです
登って崖の上に乗ってからはしごを捨てちゃったんです
降りられないんです ここで悟るか死ぬことにしましょうと
それで一人が最初の日で悟って
もう一人が 2日目に悟って
それでこうやってみんな次から次へと悟って悟って
悟った人は人数で崖から出ているんです
悟ってない人は凡夫だからもう降りる方法はないんです
一人がなかなか悟れなくて残っちゃったんですね
しかし その人はずっと瞑想していて
禅定まで作っていたんですね
そのまま死んじゃったんですね
死んじゃって梵天に生まれたんです
だからもうものすごい修行を積んでいるんです
そこで梵天で寿命が終わって
人間界に生まれて バーヤという人になっちゃって
それまた暇任せになっちゃって
それでブッダの言葉を聞いただけでいるって聞いただけでも来て
すぐに悟りましたけど
結局みんな同じなんですよ
アーナンダ尊者が預流果になったんですよ
ものすごい早く それからまあ
お釈迦様が 50歳でお世話役始めたんだから
55 か 50 歳の時にね
30 年間ぐらいお釈迦様をお世話したんですね
で その間毎日仏教を聞いているでしょ
暇があったら瞑想もするでしょ
で でもお釈迦様のお世話することは義務だから
そこはもう解脱に達したら
そこできないんです 阿羅漢方からはお世話してもらわないお釈迦様は
ですから 意図的に悟らないでいるんですね
そこで自分の師匠であるカッサパ尊者がね
お前はまだ汚れているんだから
血筋に入れませんよと
明日だよと  1日しかあげてないんです
それで一晩で悟るんですね
完全な阿羅漢になるんですね
だからといって瞬時に悟れるということはね
それ長い間の経験の結果ですよ
だからそこは仏典ごまかしてないんです
はっきりと過去世でどれぐらい修行を積んだかということは説明してあるんです
皆様ももし根底全て揃っているならば
即座に悟りに達する なかなかまだまだね
修行経験足らなかったら
今瞑想することはまた何と言いますか
足し算になるんですね
そういう感じで 完全に智慧が現れた瞬間で悟りには達します
で これちょっと複雑なところなんですね
だから私ももういい加減ながら感じますよ
この人ならできそう この人はちょっと時間かかるでしょとかね
だけど この人ならできそうとわかったっても
それだと私は個人的に心の中身まで読んで話し合って
対話してアドバイスしなくちゃいけないとなると
そのチャンスができてこないんですね
なんとか逃げちゃうとかね
その場合はやっぱりまだまだ修行する羽目になっちゃう
そういういろいろありますね
それから預流果に達したとしましょう
預流果に達したら 涅槃に入ることは確実
もう絶対的に決めた でも不還果になるまで一類果になるまで
不還果になるまでどれぐらい時間がかかるかということも
その人次第なんですね
だからこれぐらい時間ということをちょっと言いづらいんですね
ないんです 仏教の答えとしては
そういう固定した日にちでは決められるものじゃないです
理由は これは存在欲を断つこと
執着を断つことだから
これはものすごく難しいことなんですね
生きながら死になさいということと同じですから
なんか矛盾で感じちゃうんですね
執着があって生きているんですね
生きているから幸福にもなりたいし
解脱にもなりたいし なんかいつだってなんか矛盾があるんですね
だからそこを破らなくちゃいけないんですね
だから生きながら死ぬっていうことだったら
どうする？わからなくなるでしょうね
だからこの存在欲を断つこと
執着を断つことは容易いものではありません
智慧が現れたらできることで
まあ我々はもう修行すれば悟るでしょうという確信を持って修行はするんです
悟らなくても大丈夫です
そこはまあ無効にはなりません
ヴィパッサナー瞑想の場合は
そこでなんでいきなり悟れって言わないんですかね？なんで喜び苦不苦
嫌悪苦不苦 阿羅漢か四段階で
それはこの存在欲をじわじわ足すんですね
だから そのそのどこまで自我意識がまず自我意識が消える
それでも自分という意識だけ
自覚だけ残っている それで自覚も減っていくという順番で四つのステージになっています
質問されたような感じで時間が来るということはないんですね
はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
他にどなたか じゃあそちらの方からいきますね
えーと あの 会社のことはあんまり詳しくは話せないんですけども
つい二 三日前に六年間勤めた会社を退職しまして
いつかスマナサーラ長老の忍耐と管理の話とか聞いたことがあって
そういった時に大事なお話を聞いたなと思って
その時も会社に耐えていて
でもその話を聞いたおかげで
もっと暴力とかそういうことにはならなかったから
聞いてよかったなと今まで思ってるんですけど
でもやっぱり先日 これを続けるのはおかしいんじゃないかと思う限界になって
自分で辞めないとストップしないと思ったので退職したんですけども
新薬の製品開発とか製造ラインにも入りまして
最近は薬事申請の仕事をしていたんですけども
バイオ分野なので倫理問題とか
人から細胞をもらったり
人の体から検体を取るような話が出てくるんですけども
まあ自分が受けてみる気になるかわからない検査を
検査とか治療を人に勧めるのはどうかなと悩んだりしたんですけども
今一からスタートになってしまって
次の仕事も決まってないけど
とにかく辞めたっていう状況なんですけど
何か何かアドバイスとか
何かお言葉をいただきたいと思うんですけど
うーん このままね 私たちはものすごい生きていけ
生きていかなくちゃ 生きていかなくちゃという
そこをすごいなんかストレスを感じて
責任を感じてね なんか大変なことをやって
感じで それからやばいというね
これやらなくちゃ あれやらなくちゃ
やばいという風な この精神的にものすごくクタクタやられているんですよ
そこですごいいい加減になった方がいいんです
こんないい加減 どうせ生まれたんだから
死ぬまで生きるでしょうにと
そんなに真剣にあれやらなくちゃ
これやらなくちゃっていうことがなくても
どうせ生きていられるんだと
例えば あまり良くない言葉なんですけど
例えば仕事がなくなったっても
生活保護でも受けてやるとかね
そうやってこの生きること自体はどうせ流れるものであると理解しなくちゃいけないんですよ
人間が修行して解脱に達しない限り
輪廻転生をする 生まれたら業で生まれたんですよ
業が尽きたら死ぬんです
仕事をしたからといって
仲間と仲良くやっているからといって寿命に影響ないんです
会社でいじめられたからといって寿命に影響ないんです
しかし 我々は業をクタクタ
もう叩いて壊しちゃうんですね
それだけやめればいいんです
だからいじめられた いろいろやられた
言われた あれやこれやと言いちゃうと
なんか気持ち悪いでしょ
この気持ち悪さで自分の業が隙間だらけになっちゃうんです
だから気持ちよく まあどうせ業で生まれたんだからね
業が終わったら死ぬでしょうと
その間でなんとか適当にやっているんだよという気楽さで生きてみてください
悪い言葉で言えば無責任でいいんです
まあいいや 別にという感じで気にしないよと
気にしないよと生きていて
今のことはやる それだけ
今掃除する ああ 掃除やりますと
今料理作らなくちゃ ああ
料理作りますよと いう感じで
今のことはやるっていう感じで
極端にリラックス状態で生きてみてください
あまりにも将来のことを考えたり
命のことを考えたりとかすると
かなりクタクタ状態になりますね
何がはい 何があったっても
まあ別にどうったことはないという感じで
何だって人間に起こるものやとという感じでやってみてください
とにかく笑顔を絶えないようにしてください
人間というのは笑顔が好きですよ
自分が笑っちゃうと世界は怒りで返すことできないんです
だからいつでも負けた顔をしないでください
いじめられた顔とかね
やられた顔とかね そうしちゃうと悪循環でさらにやられちゃうんですね
だから笑顔でいる訓練をした方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
はい 以上です  はい ではあちらの方
2つ質問があります 長老の話が私にとってすごくありがたくて
私はちょっと耳が悪くて
はい 長老の話が私にとってすごくありがたくて
生活の中で少しずつ実践させていただいてます
ただ 先ほど執着という話がありましたけれども
そういうお話を執着しながら生きているのかなって時々感じることがあるんですけども
そういう執着はどう考えればいいのかっていうことが一つです
あと単語を聞こえなかった
単語を聞こえなかった
えーと 長老の話に私が執着をしてしまって
なるほど はいはい 執着
はい  執着して生きているのかなと感じることがあって
その執着をどう考えればいいのか
なるほど  ということが一つ
はいはいはい  と もう一つは
人と人との対立をどう解決していけばいいのかっていう話なんですけども
例えば ある組織で上の人と下の人が方針で合わないとか
方針は合ってるけどやり方が合わないとかっていうことを解決していく上で
妥協ではなくて どうやって解決していけばいいのかっていうことをしたいと思いました
はいはい じゃあ質問 1
で 私の話に執着するんじゃなくて
私はお釈迦様の教えを言ってるんだから
私は自我を張ってるわけじゃないんです
自我がない世界だからね
で 誰かの話って言わなきゃ
俗世間的に成り立たないんだから言ってるし
お釈迦様から教えてもらったんだから
感謝を込めてお釈迦様の話
こうだああだこうだと言ってますね
お釈迦様にさえ執着する必要はないんです
私だけじゃないんです
そこで問題は 大した問題じゃないんです
スマナサーラの話に執着するのはではなくて
真理だから真理に執着する必要はないでしょう
例えば地球が丸い その考えは真理でしょ？事実でしょ
誰も執着するんですかね
スマナサーラっていうのは人間なんですね
だから人間の欠点とやらね
制限と全部持ってるんですね
だからスマナサーラが言う言葉は不完全で
いつでも異論成り立ちます
否定することもできる
認めることもできる だからといって真理事実ではないんですね
だから私は喋る場合はスマナサーラという人間を捨てて
今日もそうでしょ？ブッダの話はこういうものでとか
私はブッダよりもこの 4種類の受相に強調したんです
それが真理です 執着する必要はないんです
お釈迦様はこう言ったんです
ブッダを守る必要はありません
ブッダの教えを守る必要はないんです
なぜならば真理だからと
間違ったことを言っちゃうと守らなくちゃいけない
例えば私に執着しちゃうと
私は間違ったことを言いますよ
よく時々 時々じゃないね
結構言います うん で そうすると私に執着する人が私を弁解しちゃうんですね
執着あるんだから 子供が間違いを起こしちゃっても
お母さんかばってあげるでしょう
大変なんですよ だから
私の間違った言葉を他人に弁解しようとしたら
その人もやられちゃいますよ
逆に だからスマナサーラが言ったことに間違いだったら
あれは間違いだと言った方がいいんですね
だから真理に執着する必要はないんです
成り立たないんです 地球が丸いということは執着にならないでしょう
太陽のおかげで生きているんだよというけど
太陽に執着する必要はないでしょう
そういうことで 一切は無常という言葉に執着する必要はないんですね
だから 私の話を聞く場合でも
たまに私 個人的なことを混ぜてしまう可能性もありますしね
それはフィルタリングして
あれは個人の意見 時々私はこれは私の主観であると言います
はっきりと その場合は
これはこの人の意見だから
まあ適当に理解する これはブッダの言葉と言ったら
これは真理 それはそのまま理解することになりますね
ですから あのスマナサーラに執着するどころか
ブッダに執着することさえも要りません
我々はお釈迦様が偉大なる師匠だから
尊敬の気持ちを持っているだけ
おかげさまで助かりましたと
ありがとうございます
という執着ではありません
はい 次はこの人間の対立の問題なんですけど
これはもうちょっと理性で見ましょう
世の中で似ている 2人はいませんね
だからみんなそれぞれ様々なんですよ
それだけです みんな互い違うなあというだけで落ち着きましょう
直すに 直すに生きる必要はないんです
自分の意見あって これは自分の性格だから
人が認めるかも 否定するかも
どうでもいいんです そんなの
人はそれぞれ違いますということを理解しておけば
この人間の対立関係が
まあ何と言いますか なんとかなります
対立はなくなりません
対立は気持ち悪くなるのは
この我は正しいという感じでやる方なんですね
ブッダの教えを知っている人は
対立があっても我は正しいというふうには取らないんですね
これは私の意見ですと
それで終わっちゃうんですね
だから人間のことを観察してください
上司のことを観察してください
みんな我は正しいという態度をとっているんだから苦しいなと
我は正しいということはなくなっても
対立はあります それぞれは人は違いますよ
例えば お釈迦様の弟子たちがいたでしょ
みんな性格違うんですよ
アーナンダ尊者が話は上手で
人間関係人気者で それからものすごい物事をしっかり覚える
記憶力は世界一で それにサーリプッタ尊者がすごい違う性格
智慧は第一で 人間としてはものすごい控えめで
あんた誰ですかとわからないぐらいの存在感を控えている
しかし お釈迦様の第一の師匠なんです
弟子なんですね それでウパーリ尊者という方が
アーナンダ尊者と一緒に出家した方なんですけど
アーナンダ尊者よりは先に悟ったんですね
阿羅漢になったんです
あの方は法律家なんですね
だからブッダの教えよりは
ブッダの戒律に対してはものすごい優れた能力を持っていたんですね
それぞれのをね お釈迦様の阿羅漢になった弟子たちの間でも個人差があるんですね
でも 自我がない世界だから
みんな対立はしなかったんですね
あ この問題ならサーリプッタ尊者に聞きましょうと
あ これはモッガラーナ尊者に聞いた方がいいんじゃない？とかね
あ 問題起きた アーナンダ尊者に聞きましょうと
そうやって それぞれの能力に合わせて仕事をしてもらったんですね
俗世間ではね そこはなかなかうまくいかないね
だから俗世間だからね
仕方がないんです あ この仕事はなになにさんに頼んだ方がいいんじゃない？ってならないんだよね
いえ 俺がやってやると
マジで上がる 俺がやってやると思ったっても
下手くそでできないでしょうに
それでももう何回何回も繰り返しながら
働き幕なんですね なんか自分の仕事はどうしようもない人に任せちゃうと
なんか自分の立場がなくなったという自我が割り込んできて
そういう問題はずっとあるんですね
政治家の方々 みんな自分が総理大臣になりたいと夢持ってるでしょ？そんな感じなんですよ
でも なれたっても 総理の職果たせるかどうか
また別なんですね そういうことですよ
だから結論 全ての生命は互い違います
奥さん 夫婦間でも別々人格です
母親と子供は別々人格です
似てないんです というわけで
それを理解してうえ 理解した上で仲良くします
相手を自分の教えに洗脳するものではありません
そういう気持ちを理解して頑張ってみてください
はい 以上です  はい 他に
あ 今川本さんにも質問があるそうで
川本さん 質問あるんですか？じゃあちょっと先にこちらの質問の方から
えーと どなたの方でしたかね
今日はお話ありがとうございました
えーとですね お釈迦様が昔
大昔のブッダの時代にろうそくみたいなものを捧げて
それからその 何て言うんですかね
昇格者になることが決まった
ブッダになることが決まったっていう話を聞いたことがあるんですけど
その最初にお話が出た
あの 誰だっけな すごい速度で悟りに至ったって
昔仏教の修行をしていた人がいたっていう話もあったんですけど
あの輪廻を跨いで 生と死を跨いで
その ...また仏教の教えに巡り合うようになる方法っていうのはあるのかどうかっていうのをちょっと教えていただきたいんですけども
それはね まあ宇宙の問題もありますからね
これは気が狂うほど宇宙時間で考えなくちゃいけないことになりますけど
そんなに難しくないんで
だから輪廻転生するのは私の識ですね
識は自我ではない 瞬間瞬間無常で消えますけど
次の生まれを作るのは識なんですね
それでこの今識を育てておけば
その育てた能力は次へ次へとコピーしてコピーしていくんですね
だから仏教用語では誓願という言葉がありまして
もう今はできなくたっても必ず解脱に達しますと心に言い返しちゃうと
なんか心の中にチェータナの意志ですから
それはね その意志が入って識に影響を与えるんですね
存在欲にも影響を与えるんですね
存在欲の形が変わるんです
とにかく死んだら生まれ変わってやるぞではなくて
もう生まれ変わるのは仕方がないんだけど
一応道をちゃんと変えていきますという風になっちゃうんですね
そういうことであの誓願するんですね
そうすると いつでもその不祥しいところに生まれるということはあり得るんです
誓願して善行為をして心清らかにする
今日教えたことをやってみればね
それに誓願というね トレーニングする
このプラン 企画も入れておけば大丈夫じゃないかなと思います
だからブッダが次のブッダはいつ現れるのかどうかね
この地球が破壊したら
次の世界はどうなるか
こんな気が狂う話で だからそこにはあまり関わりは持たない
持たないで 自分の心に頼ってプログラミングすればいいとは思いますよ
で 物語は物語でね 私もどんな程度で理解すればいいかよくわかりませんだけど
私は正直に個人的には物語そんなに正しいと思ってないんですよ
ストーリーだからね ストーリーは面白く書けますよ
私はこのストーリー言わんとするポイントだけ取るんですね
例えば 長い間修行しなきゃ小学生
小学生にはなりません
それは当たり前 因果法則です
じゃあ小学生になってやるぞと決めたならば
その決める資格が必要なんです
高校生が東大に入ってやるぞと決めたならば
その高校生のなんとか点数がある程度高くなければダメでしょ
あれ なんて点数っていうんですか？偏差値
偏差値の方がすごい高いんだったら
OKOK 東大挑戦できるぞと
だからそこも誓願でしょ
東大に入ってやりますと
まだ試験を受けてないんですね
だから他の大学を目指さないで東大を目指す場合は
偏差値で資格取っているんですね
そういう風に小学生になってやりますと自分もと思ったとか
阿羅漢になるぐらいの能力が
偏差値が必要なんです
本当は修行すれば阿羅漢になれる
偏差値がすごい高い そこでブッダになりますと入れ替えるだけの話ですね
そのとこだけ私は受け取って
エピソードは適当にほどほどは受け取ります
そういうことで 私たち一人一人にも
まずお釈迦様の言葉から言うと
この世で悟るように頑張ってください
可能性は大いにあります
でなきゃ仏縁に出会うこともないでしょう
人間で生まれて ある程度で生きていられるね
経済的にはハチャメチャ豊かだったら悟れませんよ
そこでやられますからね
だから まあまあ生きている状態で一番いい状態なんです
なんとか間に合って生きてるんだと
ということは 心もそんな汚れていないし
その上仏縁もできたし
で 皆様ね 純粋にお釈迦様が直接お教えを聞くチャンスも得たし
これ重ねてみればすっごい何億倍のチャンスでしょ？だからもしかすると
そういうことで その気持ちになってください
で 失敗していても それは気にする必要はないんですね
今真面目に修行していた解脱を目指して修行していたんだから
その能力は四季にヴィンヤーナに残るんです
大丈夫です はい 以上です
はい ありがとうございます
はい どうぞ  すいません
涅槃経というお経を日本語で読みますと
鍛冶屋のチュンダという方がお釈迦様にお布施をして食事を差し上げた
それがキノコの料理だったのか
豚の料理だったのか お釈迦様はそれにあたってですね
非常に下痢をなすって
体力を消耗されて亡くなったんですけれども
阿羅漢であろうとですね
生存欲は存在欲はなくても
体を維持するために食欲はある
で かつ悪いものを食べればですね
それを体外に排泄しようとする
これもある意味で存在本能というんですか
存在欲で それによって亡くなったというふうに解釈できるわけですが
阿羅漢といえども そうすると
その素人的には たとえ阿羅漢になっても
自分では意識できないけれども
存在欲というものは広い意味ではあるんだというふうに思いたくなるんですが
そこはどうなんでしょうか
はい その思考が生まれたのは
最初に間違いを犯したんですよ
お釈迦様が最後に見せなかったのは
キノコか豚肉かということははっきりわかりません
でお釈迦様はね 肉の料理いただいたら食べるし
当時のインドでは生贄ややっていたんだから
肉はいくらでもありましたしね
どうったことはなかったし
それで存在欲で召し上がったわけじゃなくて
チョンダのところに行く前にも
3ヶ月とか前からもお釈迦様のお腹が壊れてあったんです
で 腸が弱かったんですね
ですから 壊れていた弱い腸にね
何入れたっても入りませんね
それでお釈迦様が今日涅槃に入るを知っているんです
今日は人生は終わり ですから
食べ物に気をつけなくちゃってありえないでしょ
いらない まず お腹が壊して下痢になることは
もうその前からもう 3ヶ月間もあった病気で
そんなに大げさなことではありません
で ただ精神力で涅槃に入る日にちまで待っただけで
阿羅漢になったら 広く見ても狭く見ても存在欲は一切ないんです
細胞たちは機械のように変化しているだけで
それも普通の人間とは違った変化なんですね
で とにかく生存しなくちゃということじゃなくて
細胞は遺伝子っていうのは寿命は短いんで壊れるんです
壊れたらこの壊れた半分に自動的に他の物質がつなげてくるだけ
その縁起がね で それだけ起きてるんですね
それでもある回数が終わったらもう壊れるんでしょ
で それだけなんですね
ですから この存在欲は全くないんです
そこで存在欲なくないからといって
存在欲ないからこそ早く死ななくちゃいけないと欲も生まれてこないんです
だから生きていきたい人に自殺したい気持ちが生まれるんだからね
それ生きていきたい気持ちが消えたら
自殺したい気持ちが出てこなくなっちゃうんですね
こういうことを 例えば
この 車を運転する 車を運転するぐらいいつでもガスあげなくちゃあかんでしょ
車にアクセルレーター踏むんでね
で アクセルをずっと踏んでいる間は
前に行きたい 行きたい
行きたい 行きたいっていう気持ちで
存在欲で車が進むんですね
それで ガスペダルから足を外す
もう入れない どうなる？車はある程度で進んで自動的に止まる
ブレーキペダルは踏む必要はないです
で そんな感じで我々はずっと存在欲でガスパドルを踏んでいるんですね
阿羅漢になったらガスパドルから手を離す
手じゃなくて足を外すんですね
それで残った縁で生きていて綺麗に止まるんです
存在欲は関係ないんです
あれは日本語で読むんだから
大乗仏教的に解説入ってるんですよ
パーリ語ではそういう風には出てこないんです
食べたものは何であってもいいんで
もう一つパーリ語では解説はありますよ
このチュンダさんが 最後の食事が自分が行いますと
輪廻の中で凄い誓願して生きた人なんです
だからチュンダさんにとっては
自分がせっかく誓願して修行を積んできたことだから
それは実らなくちゃいけないんです
だからお釈迦様がそっちにとっては食事は断れないんです
最後の食べ物は体に入っても入らなくてもどうでもいいことで
ただ最後の一日だから
毎日 1 食召し上がるんだから
そこはまあ普通に 1 食入れたんですね
これからは誰の食事も取れない
その夜 朝方 涅槃に入られたんです
その日で まあそれだけ
それからもう一つは注釈書で説明ありまして
お釈迦様の最後の食事から結構手を加えなくちゃいけないということで
神々も応援してたんだと
だから神々もお釈迦様の体も弱いし
だから体が良くなっても
その人で亡くなるんだから涅槃に入るんだから意味がないんです
いろいろ栄養を入れたみたいですね
それでお釈迦様が こう考えたんですね
これは聖徒学者にあげる最後の食事として作られたもの
この人は輪廻転生しながら修行を積んで
この善行をする目的で生きてきた人です
だから この食べ物は食べる資格は学者にしかありません
もし他の大阿羅漢であっても
食べたら消化できなくて亡くなるんです
食べてはいけないんです
だからお釈迦様には消化できたんです
消化不良ではなかったんです
消化できたってもう意味がない
下痢はずっとあったし
だからまあ その日で穏やかに涅槃に入られたんですね
それでお釈迦様ははっきり言ったんです
順番 このあなたが作ったこのスーカラマッダワっていう食べ物は私にあげてください
お坊さんたちに他用意した食べ物をあげてくださいと
お釈迦様が食べて残したものも
誰にも微生物にも食べられないように処分するんです
微生物さえ食べられないんです
そういうことなんですね
実は だからあの邪見に陥らないでください
阿羅漢になっても存在欲があるんじゃないかなと
ないんです それははっきりしています
ありがとうございます
すみません もう一つ 今日のお話でですね
タンハーという言葉は存在欲というふうに日本語で言うようなんですが
十二因縁の経というのがどっかで読んだことがありまして
あれは一番最初にアヴィッチャーというのが来ましてですね
で その次にサンカーラだったか
名色で それから六処で
今日のお話の時から処という処だったか何だったか忘れましたけど
その後にタンハーというのが出てくるんですが
このアヴィッチャーとタンハーとは
アヴィッチャーの方がより根源的なもののような気がするんですが
アヴィッチャーというのはタンハーとは違うんでしょうか？ まあすべて一緒ですよ
だからアヴィッチャーからタンナーあるって
時々お釈迦様はアヴィッチャー
タンナー一緒にね 一緒に一つにして語る時もあるしね
アヴィッチャーというのは根源的なものというよりも
如実に観察していないということを言っている単語なんですよ
特別割愛みたいなポジティブというか
肯定的な単語じゃないんです
アヴィッチャーは あるいは否定的な単語ですよ
アヴィッチャーも妙なんです
まだ勉強していないだけの話なんです
そうすると根源的と言いたければ言えますよ
例えば皆様方にギリシャ語を知っているかと言ったら
みんな知らないと言うでしょう
なぜならば まだ勉強していないんです
勉強したならばできるようになります
だから如実に見て見てないことにアヴィッチャーと言うんです
だから全ての生命がアヴィッチャーから始まるんです
それだけです  では 川本さん
はい  えーと 執着をどんどんなくしていって
執着が完全になくなると純粋な意識が現れるとおっしゃったんですが
その純粋な意識というのは解脱のことなんですか？ そうですかね
解脱する時の心ですね
それは消えちゃうんですか？意識は残るんですか？ いえ
残らない それも無常だから消えます
解脱した段階で消えて
いえ それはいつでも作れます
生きている間はいつでも解脱の心作れます
作れたらもうものすごい穏やかさ
安穏感じますよ お釈迦様も日常生活ですごい肉体が疲れてくると
寝ないで瞑想禅定に入って解脱の心に入っちゃうんですね
そうすると全て消えちゃって
安穏状態にいられる それでまた細胞たちが復活して元気になります
で ヴィンヤーナナンアニダッサナアナンタンサブドパワンというパーリ仏教でお釈迦様が説明してありますね
涅槃に達するヴィンヤーナがもうこれというふうに言えるものではありませんと
意識はね だから私はその説明今日しましたからね
本当は言葉を変えて 別な言葉で
それはすごい もう無限に広がる力であると
だから常留性みたいなものってどこにもないんだけど
理論的にはあるだけいてね
だから心のすべて 執着を消えたら純粋意識だけ残る
肉体があるんだだから純粋意識だけ残るんですね
それは涅槃の心なんです
はい ありがとうございます
はい そろそろお時間の関係です
はい ではもうお一方 はい
すいません 時間がありますね
皆さんのちょっと難しい話をちょっと聞いてて
ふと思ったんですけれども
死んだ時にですね お坊様をみんな呼びますよね
それは何か助けなんかあるんかなと今単純に思ったんですね
阿羅漢とかその辺はわかりませんけど
偏差値の低い者としては
お坊様は何か亡くなった時にその力を借りれるものがあるのかなとかいうことがちょっとふと思いました
お坊様が亡くなった時
お坊様が何か力を貸してくれるんですか？ これは文化的なことなんですよ
だから助かり 助けてあげることはできます
できるんだけど これ 文化的な問題が割り込んできて
私は例えばこの日本の病院に行って
亡くなろうとする人にね
いろいろアドバイスすると怒られるだけでしょ
そうすると助けではなくて逆になっちゃうんですね
仏法僧に怒って怒り憎しみを作ったりとか
自分の国とかミャンマーだったら仏教文化だから
もうそろそろでしょうとわかったら
医者ではなくてお坊さん呼ぶんですね
だから今お坊さんと仲良くする時間だと言ってお互い話したりする
お坊さん 出家を見ただけでも
自分の心は俗世間から離れて清らかな心になるんですね
それで私たちはそういう説法の話とか
無常の話とかね 言って大丈夫だよということを言ってあげるんです
あんたはよくいいことをしましたね
修行もしましたし 家族も養っても放っておいたし
だから人間としてはまあやるべきことをしっかりやったんだから
まあ執着捨てて明るい気持ちでいてください
そうするともう必ずものすごいしっかりしますよ
次 いいところに生まれるんですね
日本の方々 時々私に聞くんですね
自分のお母さん おじいさんとかね
まあ最後ギリギリですけど
どうすればいい 私は教えてあげるのは
このあなたは親戚だから
娘だから 息子だから 耳元で慈悲の瞑想でもしてあげてくださいと
そうすると ちらちらでも慈悲の言葉が聞こえたならば
慈しみの心が生まれるので
生まれたら次の生まれがすごい清らかな幸福なところで生まれる
助けてあげることは可能ですよ
可能ですけど 文化的にそれが邪魔になる場合もありますね
だからだから言って迷信に入らないでください
誰だって人間が死ぬ時
お坊さん呼んだ方がいいっていうことじゃないんです
イスラムの人が死にかけていてね
日本でね それで私を呼ばれて
その人はものすごくびっくりしちゃって
アッラーに逆らったら地獄に落ちるぞと怖くなるでしょうね
それは文化 なんですね
だから心って 我々の思考パターンは文化がほとんど決めちゃいますよ
日本人が日本の文化に合わせて思考妄想する
私はスリランカ人ですけど
長い間坊主やっていたんだから
十四歳から七十一歳になるまでね
だから坊主としての思考しか持ってないんですね
スリランカ人的な思考を持ってないんです
だから文化っていうのは長い間組み立てることでしょう
だから思考パターンで助けてあげることはできます
それでよろしいですか？ はい
それではちょうど時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
では皆様ご一緒に経を読んでください
ドゥッカパッターチェニンドゥッカ
バヤンパンターチェニンバヤー
ショーカンパンターチェニッショーカ
ホントゥサンデーピパーニノー
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい どうもありがとうございます
サーリサーリサーリ  サーリサーリサーリ